what's really exciting is that there's a
there's a magnet around this sword
that's that's divinely placed in the
earth that then radiates out this magnet
magnetic field called New Earth and it's
fascinating cuz that magnet itself is
such an attractor to those that are
already feeling within themselves the
godhead they're feeling completeness
within themselves they're feeling
themselves as the totality they're
feeling themselves as Christ as giving
themselves full to the collective
transformation so that is literally the
magnet that is the magnet and then
there's a gravitation to that portal the
magnet is a portal it's a gravitation to
that portal you're you're being invited
through this content and through more
content to come you're being invited
into that portal for this for this and
for your gift within this